und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat es heute noch
einmal bekräftigt Deutschland liefert
Waffen an die Ukraine nur in Absprache
und im Gleichschritt mit seinen
Verbündeten nun scheint es aber so dass
manche Partner in Europa ihre Zusagen
gar nicht einhalten können Spanien
sprach von zunächst vier bis sechs
Leopard Panzern die Niederlande wollen
sich nicht festlegen Portugal prüft da
scheint was mit der innereuropäischen
Kommunikation nicht zu stimmen und auch
in Deutschland geht die Debatte weiter
die Kanzlerpartei SPD versuchte diese
Woche auf verschiedenen Veranstaltungen
ihre panzerpolitik zu erklären Eva
Schiller und Max schwarz berichten
Willy Brandt und die rote Linie das sind
derzeit die Wörter die am häufigsten
fallen unter SPD Mitgliedern und während
für Demonstranten draußen die rote Linie
mit Kampfpanzern längst überschritten
ist hat sie sich drinnen am
SPD-Landesparteitag in Husum schon
weiter geschoben
unterstützen zum Beispiel mit Kampfjets
oder Waffen da bin ich voll dafür
ja ich war auch dafür ich denke
irgendwann ist dann die rote Linie auch
erreicht denn allein mit Waffengewalt
wird mit diesem Konflikt sicherlich
nicht lösen können wohl wissend dass
viele in der Partei zweifeln wirkt der
Kanzler für seinen panzerkurs
dass wir Waffen liefern
das ist ein Bruch mit jahrzehntelangen
Traditionen der deutschen Politik wir
haben immer die gleiche Politik verfolgt
dass wir keine Waffen in Krisengebiete
liefern das haben wir geändert
richtigerweise weil man die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger der Ukraine nicht alleine
lassen kann die außenpolitische
Identität der SPD prägte Willy Brandt
wie kein anderer Wandel durch Annäherung
so sorgt er im Kalten Krieg für einen
entspannteres Verhältnis zur Sowjetunion
statt Annäherung setzt die SPD jetzt auf
Abschreckung und es gilt die gespaltene
Parteibasis bei diesem Kurswechsel
mitzunehmen
keine Kriegseinsätze geben das ist das
steht völlig klar und das wissen auch
die Ukraine und das ist auch die einzige
rote Linie die es gibt wir haben es nie
festgemacht dann Waffengattung
das klingt nach mehr scheint hier im
Westen aber niemanden zu schrecken rote
die der ist sind Atomwaffen
und alles was sah man noch konventionell
ist das kann man liefern man sieht auch
tatsächlich dass Sie zeitenwände bei uns
in der Partei angekommen ist und das
auch bei uns die Debatte sehr sehr
schnell ja anläuft ganz anders die
Stimmung im Osten viele Sozialdemokraten
in Leipzig empfinden die ausgerufene
Zeitenwende als Zumutung das ist eine
Rüstungsspirale das hat man ja alles
schon mal im Kalten Krieg das können wir
nicht noch mal gebrauchen also ich bin
mehr verräten das sagte er auch schon
Helmut Schmidt lieber tausendmal
vergeblich reden als einmal Waffen
liefern auch beim Bürgerdialog mit dem
Kanzler in Marburg ist die Frage nach
Friedensverhandlungen die meist
gestellte wäre es nicht eigentlich der
bessere Weg zu sagen diplomatie ist die
Alternative man kann mit Waffenlieferung
keine Kriege beenden fragen sie bitte
Putin ob er zu Verhandlungen jetzt
bereit ist
Olaf Scholz reagiert wie er immer
reagiert abwägend emotionslos von sich
selbst überzeugt die Frage ist nur wie
lange das beruhigt und ob es dem Kanzler
gelingt seine Partei mitzunehmen auf dem
neuen Kurs
und aus Berlin ist uns jetzt der
Generalsekretär der SPD Kevin kühner
zugeschaltet guten Tag nach Berlin guten
Tag
der Kanzler hat heute noch mal um
Vertrauen geworben die Entscheidung
Kampfpanzer zu liefern sei richtig aber
ein Drittel der Deutschen 38 Prozent
sind dagegen haben die den Kanzler nur
nicht verstanden
wenn der Bundeskanzler hat die
verschiedenen Sichtweisen zu diesem
Thema im Blick genauso wie die gesamte
SPD erweist ja seit Monaten immer wieder
darauf hin dass es eben kein
einheitliches Stimmungsbild im Land gibt
und dass ich Menschen Sorgen machen
übrigens sowohl welche die für als auch
welche die gegenpanzerlieferung sind
sorgen nämlich dass der Krieg noch
größere Kreise zieht und auch zu uns
kommen könnte und es ist die Aufgabe des
Bundeskanzlers und der Regierung und der
Führung der SPD diese beiden
Perspektiven im Blick zu haben energisch
zu unterstützen aber dabei keine über
alten Handlung zu vollziehen und keine
unkalkulierbaren Risiken einzugehen und
diese Balance die halten wir auch ein
Argument der Menschen die gegen
Panzerlieferungen sind ist ja dass immer
mehr Waffen den Krieg verlängern auch
sie waren ja mal gegen Waffenlieferung
müsste der Partei von Willy Brandt nicht
daran gelegen sein diesen Krieg jetzt so
schnell wie möglich zu beenden
die SPD ist eine friedensorientierte
aber sie ist keine pazifistische Partei
wir wissen auch aus der deutschen
Geschichte dass manches Gräuel das
Menschen sich gegenseitig antun dass die
manchmal auch nur mit Gewalt zumindest
temporär begegnet werden kann aber wir
sind eine Partei die nie aus dem Blick
verlieren wird das Kriege am Ende
meistens nicht auf dem Schlachtfeld
entschieden werden sondern das kluge
diplomatische Initiativen auch
frühzeitig gesucht werden müssen um für
den Tag danach vor zu planen und das hat
der Bundeskanzler ja umfänglich in den
letzten Monaten auch gemacht hat mit
vielen im internationalen Raum mit den
Chinesen mit den G20-Staaten und anderen
mehr gesprochen zuletzt gerade in
Lateinamerika weil es eben nicht aus dem
deutschen Wohnzimmer heraus entschieden
werden wird wie Frieden in die Ukraine
kommt und Selbstbestimmung in dieses
Land zurückkehrt sondern das wird eine
Sache von internationaler Politik und
ausgleichen aber noch mal wird der Krieg
durch Waffenlieferung verlängert
streng genommen ist das natürlich so
aber jetzt schauen wir uns doch an was
sonst passiert wäre hätten wir der
Ukraine gar keine Waffen geliefert also
schon am Anfang keine Haubitzen und
anderes mehr keine Flugabwehr dann
hätten wir heute vielleicht noch
Straßenkämpfe in Kiew und levif das wäre
es dann aber auch die Ukraine wäre
binnenmonaten überrannt worden von den
Russen dann könnten wir dieses Gespräch
heute auch miteinander führen aber dann
hätten wir wahrscheinlich viele
Millionen Tote zu beklagen und eine
Ukraine die es nicht mehr gäbe und
insofern ergibt sich die Antwort finde
ich von alleine die Unterstützung bis
hierhin war absolut notwendig und
richtig
die meisten oder viele Skeptiker zum
Thema Waffenlieferung Leben in
Ostdeutschland da ist der der
Prozentsatz viel höher als im
Bundesdurchschnitt ihre Partei spielt im
Osten nur noch eine geringe Rolle warum
lässt die SPD da eine Lücke die andere
Parteien wie die AFD und die Linkspartei
füllen
dem möchte ich widersprechen wir
Regieren in zwei Bundesländern im Osten
an der Spitze in Brandenburg und
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wir sind in allen
drei anderen Bundesländern in Sachsen in
Thüringen und in Sachsen-Anhalt an den
Landesregierung beteiligt die SPD ist ja
aber die SPD ist ganz klar auch einem
Osten verankerte Partei hat bei der
letzten Bundestagswahl mit diesem
Bundeskanzler dort einer vorragendes
Ergebnis auch bekommen und wir haben das
Ort des Ohr dort sehr genau der
Bundeskanzler hat ja mehrfach
bürgerdialoge vor Ort in Magdeburger
innere ich mich in Neuruppin und anderen
Orts gemacht um genau diesen stimmen
auch Raum zu geben und seine Politik
dort zu erklären und wir teilen auch mit
den vielen Menschen den Wunsch danach
dass der Krieg nicht in eine endlose
Spirale mündet sondern auch zu einem
Ende kommt aber das Ende hat eben
Bedingungen und die Bedingungen ist das
ist ein gerechter Frieden sein muss der
dafür sorgt dass Russland nicht immer
und immer und immer wieder zu denselben
Schandtaten ansetzt noch mal zurück zu
den Waffenlieferungen die nur gemeinsam
mit den Verbündeten erfolgen sollen wie
der Kanzler immer wieder sagt jetzt
stellt sich heraus dass viele EU-Partner
noch gar keine konkreten Zusagen gemacht
haben was läuft da schief
ist ja zunächst mal eine bemerkten
bemerkenswerte Feststellung man hat ja
in den letzten Wochen teilweise den
Eindruck kriegen können alle weltwolle
liefern nur die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland nicht jetzt sehen wir
Deutschland macht eine konkrete Zusage
es wird auch tatsächlich eine
Panzerkompanie geliefert und plötzlich
ist es sehr leise geworden um uns herum
Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius führen
quasi täglich im Moment Gespräche gerade
mit den EU-Partnern man muss es wirklich
so sagen in
einzelstückzahlen wird das jetzt alles
zusammengeklappt was gebraucht wird um
diese beiden Panzer die Visionen die
bataione die zugesagt worden sind und
die auch tatsächlich liefern zu können
an die Ukraine aber da sehen wir nun mal
auch die Möglichkeiten ob beim Gerät
oder gerade auch bei der Munition die
sind begrenzt das ist nicht irgendwo
eine große warenhalle in der alles
bereit stehen würde und jemand weigert
sich ist zu liefern sondern die Bestände
sind wahr
sagt Kevin Kühnert der Generalsekretär
der SPD an diesem Sonntag herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
und das Interview haben wir am
Nachmittag aufgezeichnet
der mutmaßliche spionageballon der die
USA tagelang in Atem gehalten hatte ist
über dem Meer von South Carolina
abgeschossen worden die Trümmer werden
jetzt untersucht dass das Flugobjekt von
China losgeschickt wurde hat die Führung
in Peking nie bestritten den
spionagezweck allerdings schon die Frage
ist warum China einen weithin sichtbaren
Ballon über die USA fliegen lässt um an
Informationen zu kommen die
Aufklärungssatelliten risikolos sammeln
könnten wollte die chinesische Führung
die Entschlossenheit von US-Präsident
beiden testen oder war es eine
Machtdemonstration der Ton aus Peking
jedenfalls ist nach dem Abschluss
schärfer geworden Elisabeth Schmidt
berichtet
die Hauptnachrichten in Chinas
Staatsfernsehen Beginn an Tag 3 der
ballonkrise mit dem Laternenfest kein
Wort von politischen Verstimmungen mit
den USA das Volk soll an diesem Festtag
der die Neujahrsfeierlichkeiten
abschließt nichts davon mitbekommen nur
auf der Internetseite des
Verteidigungsministeriums geht ein
Sprecher nach dem Abschluss des Balance
in die Offensive in einer knappen
Mitteilung stellt der China nicht als
Täter da sondern als Opfer die
Vereinigten Staaten haben unser ziviles
Drohnen Luftschiff mit Gewalt
angegriffen das war eine offensichtliche
Überreaktion wir bringen unseren
vehementen Protest gegen die US-Aktion
zum Ausdruck und behalten uns vor
daraufhin angemessener Weise zu
reagieren
warum flog ein drei Busse langer
chinesischer Ballon über ein Gebiet auf
dem die USA unter anderem Atomwaffen
Lagern kurz vor dem geplanten Besuch von
US-Außenminister blinken in Peking
es kann durchaus sein dass es von
chinesischer Seite ein Interesse gab da
noch mal Stärke zu zeigen um vor allen
Dingen nicht als Bittsteller dazustehen
china muss gerade mit mehreren Problemen
kämpfen erst eine massive corona-welle
dann wirtschaftliche Probleme nach den
Protesten gegen die kobit Maßnahmen
steht die Staatsführung unter Druck
Stärke zu zeigen doch wie die Welt macht
die China gerne wäre wirkte die
Volksrepublik im Konflikt mit den USA
zuletzt nicht
[Musik]
vor wenigen Tagen erst setzen die USA
strengere Regeln für den Export von
speziellen chipfertigungsmaschinen nach
China durch eine Schlüsseltechnologie
für die Herstellung von Halbleitern
Ende Januar weiten die USA ihre
Sanktionen gegen die russische
Söldnergruppe Wagner aus sie kämpfte in
Afrika und in der Ukraine damit
verbunden Sanktionen gegen chinesische
Unternehmen die die Gruppe unterstützen
Peking macht die USA im Gegensatz für
den Krieg in der Ukraine verantwortlich
die USA bauen ihre Stützpunkte im
Südpazifik aus in Japan und auf den
Philippinen Peking kritisiert die
Unterstützung Taiwans als Einmischungen
innere Angelegenheiten eine rote Linie
für die Volksrepublik aus chinesischer
Perspektive ist es natürlich auch
wichtig nicht als schwach wahrgenommen
zu werden der Ballon also als
Demonstration von Stärke die USA lassen
die Trümmerteile jetzt genau untersuchen
möglicherweise stellt sich dann heraus
ob China Erkenntnisse gewinnen konnte
oder ob diese Hoffnung geplatzt ist
und wir machen hier weiter mit den
Nachrichten und mit Gundula und der
Situation in der Ukraine im Osten des
Landes gehen die russischen Angriffe
weiter schwere Kämpfe gibt es weiterhin
in bachmut der Chef der russischen
Söldnergruppe Wagner sagte seine Männer
kämpften um jede Straße jedes Haus auch
in Harke der zweitgrößten Stadt der
Ukraine schlugen wieder zwei russische
Raketen ein trafen ein Wohn und ein
Uni-Gebäude fünf Menschen wurden dort
verletzt
das geistliche und staatliche Oberhaupt
des Iran ayatolla Ali Harmony will
anlässlich Jahres des Jahrestages der
islamischen Revolution zehntausende
Gefangene begnadigen darunter auch die
Demonstrierenden die wegen der jüngsten
Proteste inhaftiert wurden allerdings
müssen diese offenbar eine Reue
Erklärung unterzeichnen
Menschenrechtler schätzen das seit
September rund 20.000 Menschen
festgenommen und mehr als 500 getötet
wurden vielen Gefangenen drohe die
Todesstrafe
der frühere Präsident Pakistans
muscharaf ist im Alter von 79 Jahren in
Dubai gestorben dort hatte er sich seit
Jahren wegen einer schweren Erkrankung
behandeln lassen der er jetzt erlag der
frühere militärchefuscherer hatte sich
1999 an die Macht geputzt als Präsident
führte er bis 2008 eine Militärregierung
nach den Terroranschlägen 2001 wurde
muscharaft zum wichtigsten Verbündeten
der USA im Kampf gegen den Terror
die Unterbringung von geflüchteten in
Deutschland fordert und überfordert
immer mehr Länder und Kommunen die Union
fordert Gespräche über eine Begrenzung
der asylmigration
Innenministerin Faeser kündigte im ZDF
an alle an einen Tisch bringen zu wollen
weil ich sehe dass nach wie vor
Handlungsbedarf besteht und deswegen
werde ich jetzt wieder alle Beteiligten
zu einem erneuten flüchtlingsgipfel zu
mir ins Haus einladen ich werde das
diese Woche noch raus schicken die
Einladung weil ich glaube wir müssen in
einer gemeinsamen Kraftanstrengung alles
dafür tun die Kommunen zu entlasten
mit einem Trauergottesdienst haben
hunderte Menschen der Opfer der
Messerattacke von Brokstedt gedacht
unter ihnen Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Schleswig-Holsteins Ministerpräsident
Günther scholz sagte man werde niemals
akzeptieren dass so etwas in unserem
Land geschehen am 25 Januar hatte ein
vorbestrafter Palästinenser in einem
Regionalzug auf Passagiere eingestochen
er tötete zwei junge Menschen und
verletzte fünf weitere
der ehemalige Verfassungsschutzpräsident
Hans-Georg Maaßen ist nicht freiwillig
aus der CDU ausgetreten nach Angaben der
Parteispitze ließ Maßen eine bis heute
gesetzte Frist verstreichen nun soll wie
angekündigt ein
Parteiausschlussverfahren eingeleitet
werden auf Twitter sprachmaßen von einer
Schmutzkampagne wegen umstrittener
Äußerungen mit Worten aus dem Milieu der
Antisemiten war er immer wieder massiv
in die Kritik geraten
vor zehn Jahren gründete sich im
hessischen Oberursel eine Partei die
zwar ein für im Namen trägt aber davon
lebt gegen etwas zu sein die Alternative
für Deutschland AFD bei ihrer Gründung
war sie gegen die Euro-Rettung dann
gegen Flüchtlinge und Corona Regeln
jetzt gegen Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine trotz aller Skandale
Personalquerelen und der Beobachtung
durch den Verfassungsschutz liegt die
afd-bundesweit stabil bei 15% Punkten im
Osten sind es mancherorts weit über 20
Nicole Diekmann und David Gebhardt über
eine Partei die als Sammelbecken für
zornige und empörte begann und seither
immer weiter nach rechts rückt
18 Männer am 6 februar 2013 Gründen eine
Partei als Reaktion auf Angela Merkel
sie ist Kanzlerin das Thema der Stunde
die Euro-Krise die Rettung Griechenlands
sei alternativlos so Merkels dictum das
aber sehen viele anders und ein paar von
ihnen Gründen die AFD
dieses Wort von der Kanzlerin
alternativlos zu sein lehnen Sie also
mit Abscheu und Empörung ab weil sie
eigentlich dafür sind dass wir aus dem
Euro austreten es gibt überhaupt nichts
auf der Welt was wirklich alternativlos
ist man muss alternativen formulieren
man muss sie vergleichen mit ihrem
anti-euro-kurs inszeniert sich die AFD
als einziger Alternative zum politischen
ist teppichment sie wehrt sich gegen den
Vorwurf einer ein themenpartei zu sein
und auch gegen den sehr weit offen nach
sehr weit rechts Äußerungen einiger
Gründerväter jedoch sprechen eine andere
Sprache ein Multikulti gehen führe zu
Krankheiten die vorher bei
Reinrassigkeit nicht vorhanden gewesen
sein twittert einer von ihnen und auch
der erste parteiche fällt bereits kurz
nach Gründung der AFD mit
nationalsozialistischen Vokabular auf
meine Damen und Herren wir haben so viel
an an Entartungen von Demokratie und
Parlamentarismus in der in den letzten
vier Jahren erlebt die Eurokrise appt ab
die AFD verliert ihr Thema findet aber
stets ein neues er ist die
Flüchtlingsfrage dann Corona nun
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine eins
aber bleibt die AFD immer auf
Konfrontationskurs zu den übrigen
Parteien aus Prinzip es gibt auf jeden
Fall ein continum von der Gründung der
AFD wo es sehr stark um die euro-kritik
und so weiter ging bis heute wo das das
Angst machen und dieses ähm ja in
Wirklichkeit auch auch die Ausnutzen von
Frustrationen und Ungewissheiten und und
Wut in der Bevölkerung zum Kernteil der
das Strategie der AFD gehört die
Strategie verfängt die AFD ist bereits
zum zweiten Mal in den Bundestag
eingezogen steht in den Umfragen stabil
da im Osten für sie sogar teilweise an
darum glaube ich dass wir über dieses
Jahr allerspätestens in den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern wo wir jetzt schon
stärkste Kraft sind das muss man sich
mal vorstellen nach zehn Jahren sind wir
bereits die stärkste Kraft in
Ostdeutschland dass wir dort auch
durchstoßen mit einer realistischen
regierungsperspektive das aber gilt als
ausgeschlossen aus dem anfänglichen
Verdacht die AFD flirte mit rechts ist
eine Beobachtung durch den
Verfassungsschutz als rechtsextremer
Verdachtsfall geworden besonders
Funktionäre aus den ostdeutschen
Landesverbänden Stellen demokratische
Werte und Institutionen immer wieder in
Frage der Kampf den wir kämpft um die
Existenz unserer Nationen und Europas
der wird nicht in den Parlamenten
entschieden der wird tatsächlich auf der
Straße entschieden die teilweise
radikale Abgrenzung von den anderen
Parteien lässt die AFD zwar bei ihren
Anhängern Punkten macht sie aber als
Koalitionspartner unmöglich 10 Jahre
nach ihrer Gründung ist die Partei von
jeglicher Machtoption weit entfernt
mehr darüber ob die AFD wirklich etwas
zu feiern hat erfahren Sie in unserem
Online-Format inside-politics frisch aus
dem Hauptstadtstudio in der ZDF
Mediathek und jetzt nochmal Gundula
zunächst mit Meldungen vom Sport in der
Fußball-Bundesliga hatte Rekordmeister
Bayern München die Auswärtsaufgabe in
Wolfsburg souverän gelöst die Münchner
gewann am Ende mit vier zu zwei und sind
nun wieder Tabellenführer zuvor unterlag
der VfB Stuttgart zu Hause Werder Bremen
mit 0 zu 2 Stuttgart rutscht durch die
Niederlage auf den Relegationsplatz 16
Fußball-Bundesligist hoffenheim hat sich
nach übereinstimmenden Medienberichten
von Trainer Andre Breitenreiter getrennt
damit reagiert der Club auf die
anhaltende sportliche Talfahrt mit zehn
Spielen ohne Sieg zuletzt gestern die
zwei zu fünf Niederlage bei Bochum
Breitenreiter hatte erst im vergangenen
Sommer in Hoffenheim übernommen
zum Wintersport in der Nordischen
Kombination hat Julian Schmid den
Weltcup in seiner Heimatstadt Oberstdorf
gewonnen sein dritter Saisonsieg Jubel
im deutschen Team auch bei der bob-wm in
St Moritz Francesco Friedrich bleibt in
der Königsklasse ungeschlagen mit seinem
Team feiert er Gold im viererbock und
das zum fünften Mal in Folge
in Chile sind bei verheerenden
Waldbränden bislang 23 Menschen ums
Leben gekommen besonders betroffen drei
Regionen südlich von Santiago de Chile
die Regierung rief den Notstand aus um
das Militär zu Bekämpfung der Brände
einzusetzen mehrere Menschen wurden
wegen des Verdachts der Brandstiftung
festgenommen die Feuerwehr werden durch
eine enorme Hitzewelle begünstigt
arktische Kälte dagegen im Osten der USA
und Kanadas Polarluft führt dort zu
rekord-werten
minus 78°c so eisig soll sich die
Kombination von Luft und Wind am Gipfel
des Mount Washington im Bundesstaat New
Hampshire anfühlen in der Region wurden
auch frostbeben beobachtet durch extreme
Kälte verursachte Erderschütterungen
sie haben Angst vor zeitgenössischer
klassischer Musik oder glauben damit
nichts anfangen zu können mit diesem
Vorurteil will die Elbphilharmonie in
Hamburg jetzt aufräumen abgefahrene
Kompositionen in fantastischer Location
das ist das Angebot und die zielgruppe
sind junge Leute die Konzertreihe
visions Visionen hat sich vorgenommen
das futuristische Haus eben nicht mit
Beethoven vollzukriegen sondern mit
Werken junger experimenteller
Komponisten und tatsächlich die ersten
Abende waren ausverkauft Sven Rieken hat
sich visions angesehen und angehört
[Musik]
die Elbphilharmonie traut sich was
visionäre Klänge im großen Konzertsaal
ein Orchester Sound der Neuzeit Flügel
heißt das Werk und ist verleiht den
Musikern welche dieser Streich eine der
bekanntesten zeitgenössischen
Komponistinnen weiß dass sie mit diesem
Sound aneckt das ist okay
das Wichtigste ist dass es etwas macht
finde ich ja egal in welche Richtung
ja also ich bin gar nicht unbedingt das
aber dass man was spürt das ist man
spürt am Leben ist
das das ist schön
Lisa Streich lebt in Schweden fast
scheint es als Firma man die
Perspektiven der langen nordischen
Winter und die Freude der kurzen Sommer
in ihren Werken Orchestermusik anders
komponiert Jünger gedacht
ich würde sagen die jünger desto besser
dass man damit in Berührung kommt damit
man auch so früh wie möglich diese
besonderen Erlebnisse die man da
wirklich haben kann er lebt und dann
weiter Neugierde aufzeigt
Neugierde die bis in die sozialen
Netzwerke reicht
nare sol erklärt Klassik online auch
live vom visionsfestival
new Technics
sind neuer Sound ich glaube im Vergleich
zu dem was viele so denken ist die junge
Generation viel offener für klassische
oder zeitgenössische Musik
[Musik]
zeitgenössische Musik weit weg von dem
was man wohl in einer viel Harmonie
erwartet
es war spannend die ganze Zeit und
man musste sogar gucken was da alles los
ist also in der Orchester du steckst da
in einem in einer gewissen Atmosphäre
und das nimmt schon
so emotionale Kraft von sich selbst das
zu hören
Lisa Streich weiß was man mit einem
Orchester anstellen kann und wie man
Emotionen erzeugt
ihre Form der musikalischen Visionen hat
sie eigns für die Elbphilharmonie
geschrieben
einzigartig wie das Konzerthaus selbst
[Musik]
und wie immer am Sonntag haben wir jetzt
noch unseren heute journal Ausblick für
Sie Björn Weidner hat die wichtigsten
Termine der nächsten Woche
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
am Montag wird Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck mit seinem französischen
Amtskollegen le MEr nach Washington
reisen ganz oben auf der Agenda
Gespräche über das us-klimaschutz
Investitionsprogramm weil von dessen
milliardenschweren Subventionen fast
ausschließlich Unternehmen in den USA
profitieren sollen ist die Kritik aus
Europa groß
[Musik]
am Donnerstag werden sich in Brüssel
Staats- und Regierungschefs treffen
neben den US-Investitionen ist dort auch
Migration Thema mindestens 330.000
Menschen kamen vergangenes Jahr ihre in
die EU so viele wie seit 2016 nicht mehr
dass ich endlich die gesamte Union in
Verantwortung sieht darauf drängen vor
allem die mittelmeeraner
am Sonntag wird in Berlin das
Abgeordnetenhaus gewählt die
Wiederholung der planablen chaoswahl vom
September 2021 durch eine bessere
Vorbereitung sollen Pannen diesmal
vermieden werden Umfragen sehen die CDU
vorn und Verluste für die Parteien der
regierenden rot-grün-roten Koalition der
Neuauflage wäre dennoch möglich
und das Wetter in dieser neuen Woche
bringt morgen noch mal Schnee und dann
viel Sonne etwas Schnee fällt morgen in
der Mitte und im Süden in den Tälern
auch Regen sonst zeigt sich auch mal die
Sonne bei -1 bis plus 7 Grad die
kommenden Tage werden wenn sich die
wenigen Nebelfelder aufgelöst haben
durchweg sonnig bei tagsüber -1 bis plus
6 Grad in den Nächten gibt es mäßigen
Frost
und das war es von uns für diese Woche
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit der
Krimireihe Mord in Genua und gegen 0.30
gibt es hier wieder Nachrichten in Kürze
eine heute Express und Morgen begrüßen
Sie hier Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolf
wir sagen danke und tschüss
[Musik]